- Good morning, BelieveNation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are going
to solve all of the
world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is break the rules.
Over to you, Georges St. Pierre.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Entspresso keep me going.
- I've never been afraid
to break the rules in life.
I'm not talking about break the law.
Break the rules.
Why would you want to be in this world
if it's to be like everybody else?
The most successful people
in life are the ones
that are doing the things out,
they are thinking outside of the box.
So don't be afraid to break the rules.
- So I've never been a huge fan of rules
and I'm guessing if you're an entrepreneur
and you're watching this channel,
you're not a big fan of rules either.
Entrepreneurs in general,
we are rule breakers.
We like to create new things,
we like to push the boundaries,
we want to change the way
things are done in our industry
(gentle music)
and so for that to happen,
we have to break some of the rules.
I think the rules are important
and just to understand that rules are here
to keep average people
doing average things.
And there's a lot of things in life
that you are average at.
Most things, you are average
or maybe even below average in life at
and so the rules can help you.
The rules can help you stay safe.
The rules can help you get by.
You know, if you're in the
emergency exit of an airplane,
they have rules that you're
supposed to abide by.
Unless you're an airline security expert,
like, follow the rules.
The mask comes down, put
it on your face, right?
There are rules to follow
that if you don't know anything better,
just follow the rules.
It'll help keep you on the average.
But for the things that
you're way above average on,
for the things that you
have genius level talent at
and you could be one of
the best in the world at,
for those things,
then you have to adopt the mentality
of I'm going to break the rules.
There's this great clip of Steve Jobs
who was doing an interview
and he was talking about
how the world is made up
by people who are no smarter than you.
The rules that are in place
were put there by another human being
who is no smarter than you
and if you are an expert in your industry,
you're probably smarter than them.
And so don't live your
life and run your business
according to rules that are
old and created by people
who aren't as much of
an expert as you are.
I think a lot of people
are afraid to break a rule
because that's the way
that it's always done.
And I'm not suggesting go out
and do something that's illegal,
'cause that's a whole other can of worms,
but the way things are
traditionally done in an industry.
A lot of times it doesn't
even make sense anymore.
And that's on you to not
just break the rules,
but to create the new standard.
So I'd look at my YouTube channel.
I just came back from
ClamourCon as an example
which is an event for YouTubers
and a lot of these guys are
publishing one video a week
or a video every two weeks
and part of the YouTube algorithm
that's really important
is consistent content.
Once a day is really
going to be the minimum.
When I went from once a week
to once a day, my channel shot up.
When I went from once
a day to twice a day,
my channel shot up again.
From twice a day to three times a day,
not as much, doesn't really
make a huge difference.
It still goes up but you don't get
the same returns as the other ones.
And so everybody's saying wow,
I don't know how you do it,
I don't know how you build up that team
and we're responding
to every single comment
and we're updating our tags
and descriptions and titles
and testing thumbnails
and doing all these things
that most people aren't doing on YouTube
and that's why I've had the success
that other people haven't.
And so it's setting a new standard.
Right, breaking the rules that people
thought were important
before and saying no,
this is the new path to
go and come and follow me
and I think if you have that ability,
you have that genius
level talent at something,
you are the expert in your industry.
It's not only what you
should be doing for yourself.
It's your obligation to go
out and create a new standard
for your industry and not
play to a smaller level
just because there are
some rules in place.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what is the single biggest rule
that you want to break in your industry?
What is the rule that drives you nuts
that you want to abolish and say,
this is the new way.
I'm curious, leave it down
in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Diana Gartland from dianagartland.com.
Thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word, Diana.
I really, really, really appreciate it
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Entspresso keep me going.
- We have so many rules
in life about everything.
I say break the rules, not
the law, but break the rules.
My wife has a T-shirt that says
well behaved women rarely make history.
Well you know, I don't
want to burst her bubble,
but the same is true with men.
It is impossible to be a
maverick or true original
if you're too well behaved
and don't want to break the rules.
You have to think outside the box,
that's what I believe after all.
What is the point of being on this earth
if all you want to do is be liked
by everyone and avoid trouble?
The only way that I ever got any place
was by breaking some of the rules.
After all, I remember
that after I was finished
with my body building career,
I wanted to get into acting
and I wanted to be a star in films.
You can imagine what the agent said
when I went to meet all those agents.
Everyone had the same line
that it can't be done.
The rules are different here.
Just look at your body, you
have this huge, monstrous body,
overly developed, that
doesn't fit into the movies.
You don't understand.
This was 20 years ago the Hercules movies.
Now there is the little guys that are in,
Dustin Hoffman, Woody
Allen, Jack Nicholson,
before he gained weight of course that is.
But anyway those are the guys that win.
And the agent also
complained about my accent.
He said no one ever became a
star with an accent like that.
Especially not with a German accent
and yes, I can imagine with your name,
Arnold Schwarzen, Schnitzel
or whatever the name is,
on a billboard, yeah that's
going to draw a lot of tickets
and sell a lot of tickets, yeah right.
So this is the kind of
negative attitude they had,
but I didn't listen to those rules,
even though they were very
nice and they said look,
we can get you some good parts.
We can get you to be playing
a wrestler or bouncer
or maybe with your German
accent we can get you
to be a Nazi officer in Hogan's Heroes
or something like that.
But I didn't listen to all this.
These were there rules, not my rules.
I was convinced I could do it.
That if I worked as hard
as I did in body building,
five hours a day, and I
started getting the work,
I started taking acting
classes, took English classes,
took speech classes, dialogue classes,
accent removal classes I even took.
I remember running around a
fine wine rose and a vine,
you see because Germans have difficulties
with the F and the W and the V
so fine wise rose and a vine.
I know what some of you now say
is I hope that Arnold got his money back,
but let me tell you something,
I had a good times doing those things
and it really helped me.
And finally I broke through.
I broke through and I started
getting the first parts
in TV, Streets of San Francisco,
Lucille Ball hired me.
I made Pumping Iron, Stay Hungry,
and then I got the big break
in Conan the Barbarian.
(audience cheering)
And there the director said
if we wouldn't have Schwarzenegger,
we would have to build one.
Now think about that.
And then when I did
Terminator, I'll be back
(audience cheering)
became one of the most
famous lines in movie history
all because of my crazy accent.
Now think about it.
The things that the agents said
would be totally a detriment,
it would be impossible
for me to get a job,
all of a sudden became an asset for me.
All of those things, my
accent, my body and everything,
so it just shows to you never listen
that you can't do something.
And you have to work
your way up, of course.
Run for something else first.
I mean it was the same
when I ran for governor.
The same lines that if they work you up,
it can't be done, and then of course,
I ran for governor and the
rest of course is history.
They said you have to start
with a small jump as mayor
and then as assemblyman and
then as lieutenant governor
and then as governor and they said that's
the way it works in the political career.
I said I'm not interested
in a political career.
I want to be a public servant.
I want to fix California's problems
and bring people together and
bring the parties together.
So like I said, I decided to run.
I didn't pay attention to the rules
and I made it and the rest is history.
- Let me tell you a story.
So a friend of mine and I,
we went for a run in Central Park.
The Road Runners organization,
on the weekends, they host races.
And it's very common
at the end of the race
they'll have a sponsor who
will give away something,
apples or bagels or something.
And on this particular day,
when we got to the end of the run,
there were some free bagels
and they had picnic tables set up
and on one side was a group of volunteers.
On the table were boxes of bagels.
And on the other side it
was a long line of runners
waiting to get their free bagel.
So I said to my friend, let's get a bagel.
And he looked at me and said,
that line's too long.
And I said, free bagel.
And he said, I don't want to wait in line.
And I was like, free bagel.
(audience laughter)
And he says nah, it's too long.
And that's when I realized
that there's two ways to see the world.
Some people see the thing that they want
and some people see the
thing that prevents them
from getting the thing that they want.
I could only see the bagels.
He could only see the line.
And so I walked up to the line.
I leaned in between two people,
put my hand in the box,
and pulled out two bagels.
And no one got mad at me
because the rule is you can
go after whatever you want,
you just cannot deny anyone else
to go after whatever they want.
Now I had to sacrifice choice.
I didn't get to choose which bagel I got.
I got whatever I pulled out.
But I didn't have to wait in line.
So the point is is you
don't have to wait in line.
You don't have to do it the
way everybody else has done it.
You can do it your way.
You can break the rules.
You just can't get in the way
of somebody else getting what they want.
That's rule number one.